all right this is our first viewing of
alien versus Predator have you seen any
of this movie before
okay I've seen it in bits and pieces I
seen it on TV and what I saw on TV
honestly I thought it was okay I thought
was entertaining pg-13 all the way we
love pg-13 50s
it's fucking Alien and Predator how is
it pg-13
I hear they get away with a fair amount
for pg-13 I'm hoping it's all those
pg-13 s worth actually more violent than
most our films but it's it's know should
be are come on but but we have not seen
it all the way through soon I'm already
pissed off just hearing that this is so
this is our first viewing of it and we
you will see our thoughts as it partakes
as it goes as it just started to matter
what language you try it's going to suck
either way a boo the sound I make
watching this yeah 2004 huh well that'll
be interesting hey hey come here take a
look at this
now what oh the flashing red that
everyone can see shit it's x-men
apocalypse what wait wait what some of
you may be wondering why this team has
been assembled where the fuck are the
aliens and predator why the hell it's
pg-13 I know you have a lot of questions
give this movie credit they know how to
shoot their land Hendrickson look at
that lighting look at that entrance that
is a good use of your land entrances I
hate to tell you Doug but the lighting
on him is completely bright that is just
in space creating this shit like you
walk see look normal we turn a camera
everything's dark and menacing like
houses I think he could be on the
surface of the Sun and his face would
still look like a relief map of the
Grand Canyon we don't have that kind of
time this woods we never do dreams and
croutons
the electrons from the Sun in deflected
by the ask magnetic tune
yes we're all scientists we know how it
works but thanks for explaining it to
the audience do you have a scientific
reason why no brass is coming out of
your mouth
you gotta give credit for a chain which
is early as performance okay quick show
of hands who's just here to die and
looking at it I'm thinking me possibly
living
maybe black Ripley well probably kill
this got his guy off because he sees it
doing a colonoscopy for a worm dude okay
but come on that was cool they didn't
even like hear it it was super silent
now and now this pretty boy this weird
I've never seen this director this was
strange I agree this is actually
probably his banking though you can tell
he's like he's trying to be taken
seriously I'm waiting for like the other
shoe to drop or the bottom to fall out
like Gazala bait-and-switch they bring
out their secret weapon sam neill from
the horizon it's like split this was all
just a prequel that's what that's all
right
call me ball ball
okay that's fucking gorgeous weird
Christ it's really there it's fucking
there they built that damn thing yeah
choose and to speak friend and enter
yeah you know you guys gotta start dying
you need to be running you need to be
fighting five-year heads need to be on
it's a fog machine an ancient fog
machine this was totally an Aztec
haunted house hello hello ah my job is
over when everyone is back on the boat
safely and that gun doesn't change
anything
they don't actually I think maybe when
you talk with these aliens and predators
come on me in their name it invites
conversation ah man I thought I was in
trouble you know only six hours to
retirement but you know everything to
work out all right
out of all the aliens coming out of
chess that was probably the least
impressive I'm not guys come on oh I
mean oh oh oh who are you again I was a
guy with the sky Jack's I know I'm the
guy that's gonna be ejected okay you're
and you're gonna be dead to me it
doesn't matter
yeah hyung go you fucker all you and
fuck you get my ass is a Bianca lady
fucking Rosie I'm already so much more
better than them than the people you
have just know you realize if someone
has asthma that's not how it works it
doesn't work in signs either no just
three slowly no your lungs closed up
that's not how it works
[Music]
haha ya bish more bet please hello stop
trying to make a real movie about that
shit ancient warriors would want
themselves with the blood of their kill
really need eggs why yes yeah we could
have figured that out the alien in the
present they don't like each other not
just knowing this movie now that doesn't
let dice yeah to me this is a pretty
fucking awesome movie in the last night
if I remember right that is the coolest
thing I've ever seen I've seen the top
of the veena morph and that it's good
but honestly do you not look at ya
that's all much better now that they're
not talking visual storytelling holy
shit
okay I'm just gonna call it I'm gonna
say a predator can run faster than it
uses how I see in the lead see id you
feel more sorry for that predator than
any of the people well you know what you
feel most sorry for the predator so
anyone who doesn't fucking talk yeah
nice we made it now I kill you it's part
of a culture sorry I'm sorry this is
badass yeah way better than anything
else in the movie cut the fucking Queen
just respect this needs to be one of
those motivational posters teamwork
[Laughter]
forever know what you said I'm just
gonna assume we're dead oh you got okay
so uh we just got here what did we miss
you know if I was the kid watching this
just how cool would it be you're not a
very predator no fucking awesome
turell's in there - I love your hair I'm
an animal you know maybe we should just
avoid this planet seems like every time
one of our guys goes there yeah that's
rough is it i yeah because it's really a
very blah man then become something good
ish like there was never a moment where
I was like oh no this is great like this
is anywhere close on par with the
original but like it got goodish and a
dude in the second is fucking rogue one
it wrote one's it yeah that gives you an
idea and we will see you next time
you